thank you to skillshare for supporting
this episode of journey to the micro
cosmos
if you're one of the first thousand
people to click the link in the
description
you can get a free trial of skillshare's
premium membership
[Music]
there's a lot of green in the world and
that is thanks in no small part
to the micro cosmos not only did
cyanobacteria lay the foundation for an
oxygenated earth
they laid the foundation for
chloroplasts when they were
endosymbiotically consumed helping their
host
take on their photosynthetic machinery
for most of us
the green we are confronted with every
day is a more
macroscopic kind the leaves you see on
trees and grass
and if you're on a hike you might notice
some squishy bundles of green
flush against a tree or low to the
ground
oh a moss you might tell yourself or
oh a lichen and then perhaps you move on
unsure of whether you've called it the
right thing but distracted
by the many other sites around you but
today
we're not gonna let that happen we are
going to linger
on our non-vascular plant friends
and look at them a little closer
learning more about what they are
and why only one of those things is
actually a plant
it's the moss moss is the plant
more specifically moss is a member of
the plant division
called bryophyta and when we say that
moss is a non-vascular plant
what we mean is that it doesn't have the
vascular tissue
like a xylem and phloem to transport
water and nutrients around the plant
this lack of vasculature keeps mosses
short
so that they can still transport
nutrients and water easily
and while they don't technically have
roots or
leaves as defined for vascular plants
you'll see the equivalent structures
like their root-like
filaments called rhizoids and also
these leafy parts and mosses
provide a lot of benefits to the
environment around them
they help prevent erosion and they can
provide insulation
and we've seen ourselves how mosses
provide a home
to some of our favorite microbial
companions
like it on the other hand though they
are sometimes called non-vascular plants
they are very definitely not
plants so what
is lichen
in a 2010 discovery article the
lycanologist
trevor goward described lycan as quote
fungi
that have discovered agriculture to be
more specific
lycan is a symbiotic union between a
fungus
and an algae the fungus provides access
to nutrients
as well as protection from the elements
and uv light
and in exchange the algae provides its
own photosynthetic capabilities
now that sounds straightforward enough
especially when you consider all the
symbiotic relationships we've learned
about in the microcosmos
put together the right fungus and the
right algae and you get a lichen
right well scientists have attempted to
create lichens in the lab by culturing
the appropriate partners together
but with little success and it turns out
that that might be because we've
underestimated the number of
partners involved in one study
scientists found that there was
at least one other fungal partner in
their lichens
and it could be that other species have
many many other members involved making
them
far more complex than we have understood
thus far
for something so strange and complicated
lichens are amazingly prevalent they're
estimated to cover up to around
six percent of our planet's surface
whether that's on the side of a tree or
on a rock or even on
dunes and lichens have this ability to
not only
latch onto all sorts of surfaces but to
disrupt them
and convert them into a more habitable
environment
by releasing minerals and creating the
early ingredients
for future soil and so because lichens
are so important to cultivating these
seemingly inhospitable parts of our
world
many have thought lichens were possibly
one of the first organisms to make it
onto land
but research from 2019 has suggested
that lichens
didn't find their way to land until well
after vascular plants did
in fact it could be as long as a hundred
million years after
raising new questions about how plants
and our own earth evolved
now mosses are also a part of the story
as they were likely among the earliest
plants to make it on the land
and their ancient spread may have played
an important role
in raising oxygen levels to where they
are today allowing the evolution of not
just
other plant life but of more complex
animal bodies as well
with that said the trick with evolution
is to know that creating a whole world
is much more complicated than anyone's
step would have you believe
mosses and lichens carry their own world
in their spreading masses not fully
invisible like the microcosmos
but often underfoot and easy to ignore
but maybe if you spot some on a walk
take a moment
to look a little closer and to wonder
what other secrets they might possibly
[Music]
hide
thank you for coming on this journey
with us as we explore the unseen world
that surrounds us and thank you again to
skillshare
for supporting this video after staring
on all that moss maybe you're thinking
you know
i could use more plants around the house
but you might also be worried that you
don't have the green thumb necessary to
keep those plants alive
well with classes like happy houseplants
hosted by the botanist chris
satch skillshare can make sure you have
everything you need
to pot and care for your plants so that
they live long
healthy lives that's right skillshare
you can learn python you can learn
plants
this course can teach you how to
troubleshoot for your plants as well as
more specific skills
like how to pot a cactus skillshare is
an online learning community that offers
membership with meaning
with so much to explore real world
projects to create
and the support of fellow creatives
skillshare
empowers you to accomplish real growth
it's curated specifically for learning
meaning there are
no ads to distract you and they're
always launching new premium classes
so you can stay focused and follow
wherever your creativity
takes you a premium membership will give
you unlimited access so you can join the
classes and communities that are right
for you
and an annual subscription to skillshare
is less than ten dollars a month and
if you're one of the first thousand
people to click the link in the
description you can get a free trial of
skillshare's premium membership
everybody whose names are on the screen
right now they are our patreon patrons
if you like what we do here and you'd
like to join them you can check out
patreon.com
journey2micro if you want to see more
from our master of microscopes james
weiss
check out jam and germs on instagram and
if you want to see more from us
there's always a subscribe button
somewhere nearby
[Music]
you